you and a young gentleman a struggling
actor named aaron paul
have a mescal together dos ombres yes
and um
tell me what it's like what's the
process like of picking i mean
you guys did you go through a process of
tasting a million missed calls to make
sure that you got the one that said this
is us this is what we believe in that's
exactly right
uh aaron loves a strong scotch
slap you in the face kind of drink ah
i like to be seduced and i when i taste
something is like my art or
architecture i like to be oh what is
that and be drawn
in but i i don't want to be abused
so we had to find one juice that
appealed to both of our tastes and
del sumbres is it and you know what this
is available everywhere
we didn't uh why you brought this did
you bring it yeah i did i brought that
and
this is just for me alone yeah go ahead
swig it
oh that's very good actually that is
very good that is
you know what it is it's smooth
okay you might want to ease up a little
bit on that you know what we're actually
taping this at 12
30 in the afternoon yeah so um
you really do uh you go strong on that i
commit which has always made me
a terrific potential actor
yeah i'm a little concerned about you
right now though
you should be yeah you should be uh this
is very very good andy have you had this
yeah aaron brought it to the show uh a
while ago and it's delicious it's really
good
we are andy and i are so cheap that we
won't go out and buy
this wonderful mezcal we just keep
either booking
you or aaron you always bring it
and the minute it gets low we reach out
again regardless yeah yeah
last time aaron wasn't even pushing
anything he was like i don't have a
i'm not pushing anything we're like
you've got to come we've got to talk to
you
and you should probably bring some dos
hombres bring the dos hombres because
we're running low
um andy do you want some i'll get some
after we're done
see you know i was going to pass it down
to you
you are the biggest piece of [ __ ] i'm
telling you
you really are yeah you know you got to
do uh
what god's given you guys what you got
to work with
my dad told me when i was young you're a
piece of [ __ ] and i'm like
yeah he's not i'm gonna be the best
pizza
i think that's called leaning in yeah
leaning into it